-Thank you very much.
Thank you for watching.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Tonight Show."
Guys, it was such a beautiful
spring day here in New York.
Wasn't it great? All over.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All over the city,
tulips, daffodils,
police barricades were blooming.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. Today, ahead
of his scheduled arraignment,
former President Trump
flew from Florida to New York
and landed at LaGuardia Airport.
Yep, he was smart.
Nothing helps you
ease into prison
like spending time
at LaGuardia.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Trump flew from Florida
to New York,
where he'll soon be arrested.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's basically doing
a reverse spring break,
if you think about it.
[ Laughter ]
Florida, New York, then...
Of course, all the news outlets
were covering
Trump's every move.
Even the Domino's Pizza Tracker
was following him.
[ Laughter ]
Then, at his motorcade --
as his motorcade
left Mar-a-Lago,
Trump was greeted by some of his
supporters out in the street.
Here they are.
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I saw more people
supporting O.J. than that.
[ Laughter ]
"A.C., give us a honk-honk!"
Meanwhile, Fox News released
a video of Trump supporters
waiting for him
at the airport.
And I think it looked
a little different than
everyone else on Fox News.
Take a look at this.
-Former president Trump
expected to land
in New York any moment now.
There is the live shot
in New York City...
-Interesting.
-...as they wait
for his arrival.
-I just find that interesting.
A little different.
Yep, Trump was then driven
from LaGuardia to Trump Tower,
where he's spending the night.
Meanwhile, back at Mar-a-Lago,
every staffer was like...
[ "Old Time Rock & Roll" plays ]
Yeah!
Like, let's get the party going.
Well, get this.
Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
announced that tomorrow
she's coming to New York City
for a peaceful protest
of Trump's indictment.
Peaceful, but insane.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
last night,
she was on "60 Minutes,"
and here's how
the interview started.
-We looked up some words
that have been said about you.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
-"Crazy."
"Q clown."
"Looney tune."
"Unhinged."
"Moron."
Pretty ugly stuff.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-By the 20th insult,
Marjorie Taylor Greene
was like, "Point made, Lesley!"
[ Laughter ]
And this is real --
Marjorie Taylor Greene's
interview on "60 Minutes"
was watched
by 6.66 million people.
[ Audience murmurs ]
-Ohh.
-And the devil was like,
"Don't associate me with this.
Alright? Hey!"
Switching gears,
I saw that Netflix announced
that they're gonna start
releasing fewer
but better movies.
And every actor who's ever done
a Netflix movie was like,
"Um, rude."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, this is wild -- I read
that 50 years ago today,
the first cell phone call
was made.
[ Audience oohs ]
It was exciting at first,
and then two minutes in,
they were like,
"Well, I should let you go."
[ Laughter ]
Finally, guys, you ever see
a photo in the news
and think that headline
should be better?
Well, we're gonna
take care of that right now.
It's time for
"News & Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ News & Improved ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
For example,
check out this first photo here.
The original headline was...
That headline
can definitely be improved
'cause if you only looked
at the photo,
the headline
could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Oi, Mum. Hello."
See how this works?
So, up next,
this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
"Hi! Wow, you look great."
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Yeah. Oh, yeah.
I'll text you the photo now."
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next headline was...
[ Laughter ]
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mouthing words ]
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
Eating it.
-Wow.
-Wow. Sad.
This next headline was...
[ Laughs ]
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
And finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That's all we have
for "News & Improved."
What a great show!